Okay, so the next step of the algorithm
is to the compute the nodes that are 4 hops away,
and we're going to be able to do this in a similar way.
Say we are starting with node 0 and we want the node that is 4 hops away from node 0.
So we know the node that's 2 hops away and then the node that is 2 hops away from node 2 is node 4.
We'll fill in a 4 here.
To find the node that is 4 hops away from node 1,
we know the node that's 2 hops away,
and the node that's 2 hops away from it is node 0 and so on.
And then we'll do the same thing for the last line here
and find the nodes that are 8 hops away from each of these starting nodes.
And we'll continue this progress as long as the number of hops away
isn't greater than the number of nodes.
In our example here, for instance, we have 10 nodes,
so we will compute the nodes that are 1, 2, 4, and 8 hops away,
but if we computed more, we would be going all the way around the list and beyond.
How much work does it take to compute this entire table
for N nodes proportional to N, N log N, N-squared, or N-cubed?